what is the cost of the UK monarchy I'm
Christy platson in Berlin thank you for
joining
in countries aligned with the British
Commonwealth many have been mourning the
death of Queen Elizabeth II her 70 years
on the throne make her Britain's longest
reigning Mark Monarch the loss has the
UK grappling with the question of the
relevancy of the royal family and the
cost of maintaining the monarchy
well to help us get an idea of the
economic costs and benefits of the
British Monarchy I am joined today by my
two guests we have nikhil Kumar he is
Deputy Global editor at grid a news
publication reporting on global Affairs
he's written about the Queen's death in
the context of the UK economy today and
we're also joined by DW's UK
correspondent my colleague bigot moss in
London thank you both for joining me
today I'd like to start off in London
where bigot is we've seen a huge
outpouring of grief of support for the
royal family in the days following the
Queen's death also a huge amount of
pageantry involved in these day-long
days-long Affair bigot what sort of
price tag is on a funeral like this and
could you put that in context for us a
little bit
yes I have tried to look into it and
there are no official figures there are
estimates and the estimates are that
it's about eight million pounds so that
would be about the equivalent of 9
million euros this is what other
funerals State funerals in the past
would have cost in today's money however
this is not it that would just be the
actual staging of the event on top of
that we have costs for security we have
costs for staff we have volunteer
organizations 600 volunteers are from
the ambulance from one ambulance
organization alone so and and then the
foreign office they have said that they
have put 300 staff just for organizing
the whole diplomacy uh around the
funeral so that's man hours basically
plus police they obviously they have
their their and their tens of thousands
and they will lose
um working hours on top of that you also
have fact that the Monday the day of the
state funeral is going to be a bank
holiday so the UK will also be losing
productivity so all in all it's really
not a small price tag
yeah it doesn't sound like that at all I
mean you're just mentioning thousands of
people working it on many many more
thousands attending uh Nikita I'd like
to throw a question to you now we've
seen that the queue the view the coffin
has been stretching for miles today
people camping out on the street talk to
me economically speaking what is life
for these people for these regular
people in the UK like right now
well it's getting harder
um you know when when the queen passed
away she she went off the stage so to
speak at a very very important
um and a very dark Crossroads for
Britain it is facing like so many other
countries around the world certainly in
Europe very very high rates of inflation
a lot of it banned by the war in Ukraine
Energy prices are higher the first thing
the the last Constitutional Duty that
Queen Elizabeth II fulfilled before she
passed away it was appointed new prime
minister Liz trust who's first act when
she became prime minister was to
announce a massive package to try and
shield all new britons from the impact
of these high energy bills and you know
so and that pressure will only most
likely intensify as we enter the winter
months you know this really well where
you are in Germany but it's been
historically a lot of high dependence on
energy coming in from Russia Britain
doesn't have the same direct
Independence but it is of course
affected by the price Rises on the
entire National Market there's that this
is also of course again like other
countries around the world a country
which is still recovering from and
readjusting to the world post covet so
all of these upheavals and of course I
haven't mentioned one thing yet which is
brexit right that is still something
that real effects of which are only just
beginning to be felt because soon after
Britain left the European Union covet a
ride and so now all of these things are
combining to make life quite difficult
for ordinary britons and so they're
queuing up against this very very dark
backdrop which I think also lends an
added poignancy to this moment because
this was a monarch who was there for a
better part of a century wherever you
stand uh on the arguments for against
the monarchy you cannot deny that she
was there throughout a whole series of
upheavals for this country and she
leaves at a time when it's facing really
quite a series of people and really
quite an uncertain future
yeah most certainly I couldn't put it
better myself nikhil and I mean what I
would have spoken about next is the fact
that her having been there so long uh
has and now uh having passed away it's
really a moment for the country to take
stock of where the um they are at right
now
um uh and that also means looking at the
balance sheet
um so uh just taking a look here
at that right now the UK's royal family
is funded mostly by The Sovereign Grant
which is funded by taxpayer money in the
last seven years the monarchy spent more
and more money there was a big jump in
that spending between 2018 and 2019 by
almost 20 million uh pounds a major
factor for that rise was the cost of
renovation work at Buckingham Palace the
electrical heating and plumbing among
other other things all needed
replacement after the jump in 2018 the
monarchy spent more each year after that
even in the pandemic years when many
Brits had to Kurt tell their spending
so now taking a look at annual
expenditure we just talked about how the
Royal purse grows in size each year of
the little over 100 million pounds spent
by the monarchy in 2021 the biggest
funding came from the taxpayers annual
Sovereign Grant and the deficit was
covered by the grant reserves the size
of the Sovereign Grant has also been
steadily increasing in recent years and
you may be wondering where all of this
money is going
um a big chunk a big chunk of that money
over 62 of the expenditure was spent on
property maintenance another big chunk
was spent on wages for the 491 full-time
working employees of the crown that
amounts to 23.7 million pounds last year
and a budget of 4.5 million was spent on
the Royal travel including Prince
William and Kate's trip to the Caribbean
which was met with protests and also
produced several awkward photo ops so
all in all it appears the monarchy
spends a lot of money on public
appearances is what we're getting out of
that now
so um beer get another question for you
is uh this high cost uh for the crown a
topic of discussion for Brits or has
this conversation changed at all since
the Queens passed away
that is really interesting because at
the moment I don't think it's really at
the Forefront for people at the moment
like you're seeing with these cues it's
all about this
National Unity I would say for most
people obviously not for everybody
because there are some people who always
were Republicans and who really feel
very strongly that the UK would be
better off with a elected or appointed
head um head of state but not with
somebody who is hereditary and that
there is uh you know criticism also
about her offspring that people are
saying they are married and Scandal
um just if you just think about prince
Andrew so so there are there are people
who are pointing that out but I think at
the moment it's not really where the
country is at the reporting has been
endless about the queue about people who
are really passing by and they want to
pay the respects of the queen and how
this is a very sort of very friendly
very British very orderly and very
convivial a fan I think this is really
what what's at the top of um people's
mind however we have to see what happens
when Prince Charles actually in a way
does take over he is obviously already
the king so sorry he's King Charles not
Prince Charles anymore but he he hasn't
really assumed his his normal duties and
and this is really the moment I think
when it will be crucial at the moment we
know that only roughly a good 20 percent
would say abolish the monarchy which is
not nothing and support for the monarchy
has fallen in the last decade but the
people who are sort of actively uh
driving the forces for for the country
to change and abolish the monarchy they
are definitely in the minority but will
they gain traction when the queen who
has been so immensely popular when she
you know when the in in sort of weeks
and months I think this is maybe when
this topic will come up again
right I mean of course uh as you're
saying we are seeing huge amounts of
support even if right now we're talking
about how costly this funeral is the
crown um is enough there's of course an
argument to be made as well that the
crown is quite good for for business in
the UK according to a brand and business
valuation consultancy uh brand Finance
the monarchy is quote unquote Britain's
greatest treasure uh the monarchy's
brand value was worth an estimated 67.5
billion pounds in 2017 that's the last
time an estimate was done the crown
contributes around 1.8 billion pounds to
the UK economy and costs each UK
resident just for a pound fifty a year
according to that firm
now of course the brand may have taken a
bit of a hit since the last estimate
came out we know that Prince Harry and
Megan left for the U.S we've also been
hearing a lot about Prince Andrew's sex
scandal still the family the public
they're used to these scandals and so I
want to engage for a second with this
idea of of brand value um and I'd like
to go to nikhil on this so this is a
common argument trotted out in favor of
the monarchy that it's good for tourism
that it's good for the British brand in
your opinion do you think that this
argument holds water or is their
contribution ultimately negligent
I think you know I think it is as you
say this is an argument that is very
often made by the proponent uh of the
monarchy and and you know people who
argue that it should stay there it's one
of the arguments made actually I mean
another argument that's made is that
that's where you have a head of state
who is separate from politics and and
everything that that entails but yes
this argument that it is a draw for
tourists it's a draw for people who come
to Britain and go to London walk down
the mile and you know stand outside
Buckingham Palace and take selfies and
so on and and and that is no doubt I
mean if you're in London if you're
elsewhere in that country there's no
doubt people do like that the precise
monetary value of these things you know
it's it's always tricky how how they
come up with these estimates but I think
what is true and your poly in London uh
touched on this is that now all of these
things are really going to be in
question and I think they're going to be
in question for a very very specific
reason to do with Queen Elizabeth II
which was the longevity of her Reign she
she was there for as I said a better
part for the century and so she wasn't
simply she wasn't simply somebody who
was the face of this institution she
almost became bigger than the
institution itself uh you know during
during the the very dark days of Hobbit
19 pandemic soon after it arrived she
made a public address in where among the
things that she said to reassure people
I would say that you know we will see
our loved ones again we will be able to
live lives that we were living
pre-pandemic there was a there was a
very peculiar very specific uh
credibility that attached to that image
coming from her because she had been
there through other people right she
became Monarch in the early 1950s
shortly after second world war a period
during which the whole idea of
patriotism and being British and so on
in that country assumed a whole new
significance and then she's been there
ever since during all kinds of ups and
downs I mentioned earlier the pressures
that the country is facing right now
they're not very different to the
pressures the country faced uh back in
the 1970s high inflation and external
energy shop
the queen was there she was there
throughout if you walk down the street
uh any sort of High Street in that
country and you go to a post office and
you buy stamps the Queen's face is on
those stamps and for most britons it's
always been there the question of course
now is what happens when there is
somebody new who does not have uh put
aside everything that you know the polls
have said about whether a child is
popular or not popular the one thing
that he just simply does not have he
doesn't have that sort of it's almost
like the star that Stardust of history
that sort of the queen had because she
was part of history there was I was in
London when when her death was announced
and a commentator on the BBC noted that
many world leaders and that Britain
would use this almost like a diplomatic
parrot many world leaders wanted to be
photographed with Queen Elizabeth not
necessarily because they wanted to be
photographed with the British monarch
but because this Monarch had been
photographed with other the major
historical figures over the last century
Kennedy Churchill so on and that by
getting a picture taken with her you
were part of that story right that is no
longer true
but we're we're obviously uh seeing uh
talking a lot about a positive
associations with uh Queen Elizabeth II
and uh certainly still plenty of support
today for the monarchy but bigot on a
technical level what would have to
happen actually for the British Monarchy
to be abolished and what might that mean
for the Royal Family
we're really not at this point as we've
just said so it's nothing that's really
under public sphere I've I've had a look
there is an organization that's called
Republic and they are collecting
signatures for the abolition of the
monarchy and they are
um you know not even uh at sort of 20
000 signatures so it's really
um it's really not you know people who
are actively fighting for us not a lot
it's thought that there will have to be
a referendum so the British public
you know politicians who would consider
abolishing the monarchy they must think
that they have the British public behind
them so the polls must turn in favor of
a republic then it's thought that there
should be a referendum to really make
sure that this is what the British
public wants and then basically it would
be up to Parliament of course there is a
small chance of a revolution but it
doesn't really look like it at the
moment at least
right yeah and as you're saying we
should emphasize this is really um just
a theoretical conversation of core
support for the monarchy so uh quite
strong um it is just a moment to reflect
on the future of this institution which
is what we want to speak about in
today's show
um now uh as part of the national
remembrance and farewell to the Queen
the new prime minister Liz truss she
also paid tribute to the Monarch let's
hear what she had to say
Elizabeth II was the rock on which
modern Britain was built
our country has grown and flourished
under her reign
Britain is the great country it is today
because of her
now a flourishing country are thoughts
on this bigot I'd like to throw that
question to you
yes I I think has has already alluded to
it
um at least at the moment Britain
doesn't really look like a flourishing
country it's got productivity problems
which are historic and they are also
partly a result of the financial crisis
we're seeing very slow growth the
slowest growth in the G7 as being is
being forecasted by the international
monetary fund and and we have people
here that are really dreading autumn and
winter because people are being squeezed
the real wages have been falling
inflation is rising and some people
don't know whether they can heat whether
they should heat their homes or feed
their families
the sort of a buzzword that's that's
about it and of course the new prime
minister is trying with a new package to
support people at least when it comes to
energy costs but the country is not
exactly flourishing as she said in this
address
yeah heat and eat that's quite a
striking uh phrasing on that let's hear
from people on the ground
um hear what they themselves have to say
about the situation
it goes up then I'll have to turn the
heaters off and I won't have any heating
um I don't have running hot water
because I can't afford to put the
immersion on sort of making plans of
which rooms we can heat at the moment I
mean it might be a case of just wear it
layering up
and um obviously having blankets around
just to keep warm we feel like a sinking
abandoned ship
um
there's nobody at the helm steering Us
in the right direction the squabbling
amongst themselves and they're not
focusing on the true thing and that's
the voters and the people of this
country
nikhil you've touched on this economic
precarcity of in our talks today also in
your article for grid can you add
anything to this based on what we just
heard
well you know the the the the a day or
two after Queen Elizabeth died uh among
the many things that happened in that
country it wasn't just the mourners that
you saw on the street
um and and you know the official
statements and so on you also had uh I
think it was just a day after her death
you had three of the uh major trade
unions in the country call off or at
least postpone for the moment strikes
that were meant to take place this was
postal workers transport workers and
they said that they would postpone their
strike action until after the period of
public mourning and that just gave you
you know just one example of what that
country is living through right now
because of course the strides have been
paused for now but they will take place
and they will take place because of
these pressures uh to do with inflation
Rising costs and depression that's
putting on people's paychecks and wages
and what they take home as the country
heads to winter so it's it's a very
problematic backdrop a very uncertain
backdrop and this is one of those areas
where these two things you talked about
what happens with the future of the
monarchy and as you say we don't know
um for the moment what's going to happen
with the future of the monarchy we have
well we're starting to get some sense
certainly outside Britain right with the
with the so-called Commonwealth Realms
where Charles Dawson our King
we already heard noises about
referendums taking place in those places
but certainly not in Britain for now but
but the uncertainty that does attach to
this transition as the crown passes to
Charles uh is mirrored by the
uncertainty in The Wider economy because
we mentioned the package for instance
that Liz truss announced to Shield
people from some of these energy price
hikes but you know nobody knows none of
us know given the uncertainty
surrounding the war in Ukraine what
exactly is going to happen with gas
prices on the international markets over
the next several months and so will that
mean that Liz truss's package is enough
we don't know also what's going to
happen with Britain and brexit and you
know what are increasingly you know
testy talks with the European Union of
us at the you know certain provisions of
of the divorce deal that Britain had so
there's all these there's a whole list
of uncertainties and that's when the
queen you know as I said right at the
beginning left the stage so it's pretty
it's pretty Grim it's pretty dark in in
all of these senses really
certainly now nikhil you mentioned the
Commonwealth and just to close us out I
did want to briefly talk about uh this
subject from a more Global Perspective
and so of course what we're talking
about here is the UK this death
certainly has rang out around the world
and that has to do with the UK's Global
influence and role partly as a formal
colonial power that's one of the reasons
why this is such a significant death for
the globe that role is still very much
president present today quite literally
in the form of the Commonwealth of
Nations which is an organization of
sovereign states that recognize the
British monarch as their figurehead now
here's what prime minister Liz truss
again had to say about that relationship
today
he championed the development of the
Commonwealth from a small group of seven
countries to a family of 56 Nations
spanning every continent of the world
we are now a modern thriving Dynamic
Nation
through second thing
Queen Elizabeth II provided us with the
stability and the strength that we
needed
now that was trust's perspective on the
Commonwealth today now as a reminder the
Commonwealth is largely made up of
former British colonies and there is
today a greater and greater push for the
UK to come to term with its Imperial
past and the role that that pass has
played in economic disparity that we
still still see between nations today
now get can you tell us what are
feelings from the Commonwealth about the
monarchy
well we've had mixed feelings I think
there have been in some countries
outpourings of grief but then also we've
had our other heads of countries like
for example Antigua and Barbuda say that
there will be a referendum within three
years and to see whether the the British
monarch should still be the the head of
state so it's really very very mixed and
I think that reflects also the debate
that we see here in the UK where there
has been really in the past years much
and more emphasis on uh the the the
Empire and there has been a lot of
criticism that for example in schools
the Empire it wasn't discussed
critically enough and statues were being
toppled here so it's been a really a big
point of discussion and I think with the
death of Queen of the queen this will
gain traction so we will not see the end
of the debates neither here in the UK
nor in the Commonwealth
yeah certainly and now um our
correspondent spoke to some young
Kenyans for their thoughts on her death
let's have a listen to that briefly
I don't think the death of the queen
affects me because I am I'm pretty young
and she's British right she's British
and um I'm Kenyan it doesn't affect me
that much
she balanced against all the turmoils
that was going on in the world and the
bust not only her nation into a new
century but also African nations like
ours well uh for the British who
apologize I feel apology is only a word
if you really want to apologize there
are so many stolen artifacts in the
British museum give it back to us
some sort of mixed feelings there and
now as big it mentioned we know that uh
Barbados removed Queen Elizabeth II as
its head of state last year uh though it
does remain in the Commonwealth Jamaica
has said it plans to do the same now
nikhil just to close us out here a bit
of a forward-looking question what in
your opinion do you think is next for
the British Monarchy either at home or
abroad
certainly I think abroad
um this is this is a big question for
the British Monarchy because as you
mentioned you know the Commonwealth of
Nations which is 56 countries uh within
that there is a group of 14 the
so-called Commonwealth Realms which is
where Charles uh is now King and and so
I'm not sure even New Zealand New
Zealand the Prime Minister earlier this
week she said that going to a referendum
on this question isn't on her
government's immediate agenda but she
also said that she expects that within
her lifetime certainly New Zealand will
become a republic so even in places
where you won't see an immediate vote on
this question I I'm not sure that this
this this this Commonwealth realm idea
which Britain I have to say talks about
much more you you had the prime
minister's list trusses
um statement there uh you know the word
Commonwealth comes up a lot more in
London than it does abroad uh because
arguably the wealth wasn't all that
common it went it was translated to the
colonial power which was Britain so I
think there is a big question mark there
and it you know I find it hard to see
how you know it won't uh you know the
influence of the British crown in these
places won't be eroded uh if not
completely extinguished over the years
as for the monarchy at home uh we'll
have to see a lot of it will know that
Tan on how Charles uh behaves as king he
has a history of speaking out on certain
issues um certainly to do with the
environment for instance over the years
uh the queen one of the things that
really made people respect her quite a
lot was the fact that she was just a
quiet presence she didn't really you
know intervene at all in any kind of
sort of public debate is Charles going
to do that are they going to be more
controversies
um and also you know these polls I
should just add uh to finish off the
polls that we have mentioned
which talk about support for the
monarchy most of them uh almost all of
them I think uh took place when Queen
Elizabeth was on the throne so so we'll
have to see what happens over the next
few weeks months and indeed years with
Charles as king and whether now when you
are asked that question when the picture
on your banknote or your stamp is not
you know the silhouette of Queen
Elizabeth II but of King Charles III are
you going to feel the same uh even in
the UK I you know I don't know but but
those are the things we're gonna have to
watch over the next over the next few as
I said weeks months and years as Charles
settles into the throne
right right well we're going to have to
leave it there as a quick footnote that
Liz trust quote uh from before was from
last week not today apologize uh for my
mistake there now I want to thank both
of my guests for joining me for the DW
business special looking at the economic
costs and benefits of the British
Monarchy thank you to nikhil Kumar
Deputy Global editor at grid uh who
joined us from New York and my colleague
bigot Moss DW's correspondent in London
now for our viewers I would encourage
you to check out more videos here on
YouTube including our business Beyond
series which takes a deeper dive at
topics shaping the global economy today
thank you so much for joining me we'll
see you next time